hello everyone and welcome to the second
day of the oslo esports cup this is the
first game that we are going to show
it's the one that i've chosen now but
you guys as usual are welcome to request
some other games i thought you guys
would enjoy this one the most it's uh
the first game of the match pragernanda
shakhri or mamayarov and it really shows
uh well how how to properly attack in
chess so uh let's dive straight into it
there is as usual a lot to enjoy so
prague has the white pieces and opens
with d4 uh we have d5 by mamedyarov c4c6
knight to f3 and the knight to f6 the
slav defenses on the board we have e3
and now bishop to g4 now pinning the
knight we have h3 bishop to h5 and now
knight to c3 by prague e6 preparing to
develop the dark square bishop and queen
to b3 it's uh a more common uh chase
away the bishop with the g4 before
playing queen to b3 uh but mamedyarov
not interested in any ideas as prague
played very quickly so of course um he
is uh he is uh well definitely sure that
prague knows this line very well and
prague also knows that mamadyarov knows
this line very well because the game is
actually following the game uh maderov
already played with the black pieces
against van gaal in 2013 that mommy
jared won so uh if uh
well uh having his pattern recognition
working correctly he should be feeling
very very good about the position so
here we have queen to see a queen to c7
uh and g4 chasing away the bishop bishop
to g6 and 95. now that is a beautiful
knight there so of course mamijaro will
have none of it knight b to d7 uh
chasing away the knight from e5 and now
while f4 is a good idea in most cases
here it would just be pretty bad for
white because after captures captures we
put a knight on e4 and already you can
feel that black is uh gaining control of
this game if we'll play something like
captures capture we're gonna play bishop
g2 uh let's say uh knight captures on c3
uh or even better uh
well you could play b captures on c3 but
you don't you don't even have to capture
with this pawn you could capture with
this pawn as well and uh it's the same
idea as bishop g2 we're going to capture
here be capture sent out let's say h5
and
that's a big problem for white so now
i'm not interested in any of this uh
prague would just capture some g6 as
this follows the game one call versus
mamijaro from 2013 h captures bishop to
g2 and now g5 taking away
uh the possibility of white from
executing h4 and g
and uh
f4 anytime soon bishop to d2 and not
bishop the e7 and here we reach the
position from the set game uh where uh
uh how played uh rook to c1 however here
prague just uh
castles and it is now as of move 13 that
we have a completely new game so uh we
have uh prague castling queen side
momentary most likely castle in king's
side it should be a very very sharp game
so knight b6 putting pressure on the c4
pawn we have c captures on the e5 c
captures and now you do not want your
king on the same file as the queen
probably the rook is coming to c8 as
well so king to b1 and now knight to c4
putting pressure on the bishop here so
bishop back to c1 and now b5 and this is
the case with opposite side castles or
even with the black king still being in
the center of the board uh
it's important to attack as soon as
possible even at the price of a little
bit of material so well you this can be
captured uh this night will get
remaneuvered over to the queen side
you're going to play probably king of
fate as you don't want a castle really
and your attack will start happening
sooner than white's attack in the center
or on the queen side so here uh prague
starts by attacking uh on the on the
king side he plays f4 we have b4 we have
to attack on the queen side knight to e2
and now g captures on f4 we have knight
captures on uh f4 and uh g5 now chasing
away this knight knight to d3 and now a5
and mamijarov is uh feeling very good
here uh his position is excellent he's
attacking and if he can get this a4 move
in that's pretty much it for for prague
so you you could counter this with
something like knight to c5 to
prevent uh well to stop this bishop from
guarding b4 if a4 then we can capture
here or you can play with problem plate
and that is queen the a for with check
and okay mama yara wants his king on f8
uh and now uh uh mamidarov's position is
just uh well just slightly better
however here uh prague plays uh what can
only be
called a a very serious bluff yeah it's
a it's a well it's not a bluff it's a
very strong move especially in rapid
time format uh because uh h5 is coming
each captures and g5 is coming you have
to react to this somehow and the best
way to react is to just capture it with
the rook if rook captures g captures an
h4 you have a pass pawn the game
continues uh with black being a little
bit better but mommy have played knight
captures on g4 saying okay i can always
capture here and i don't mind trading if
you capture on g5 plus i am now ready to
capture an e3 as well with both of my
knights however here comes h captures on
g5 now there's the threat of rook
captures on h8 so king g7 and now we
have g6 probably just uh playing playing
the really brilliant chess here uh
forcing mahmoud yarov
to think and takes a breath here uh
you know from just keeping his attention
focused on the queen side and that's
what it takes the wind positions like
these if your opponent is coming at you
at the queen side you have to
focus uh uh your attack on the center or
on the king side so here we have knight
c captures on e3 uh capturing with the
g9 would have been a little bit better
but again we have to remember this is
rapid chest knight captures on e3 and
i'll probably place g captures on f7 and
here we have uh knight captures on g2
but before we continue the position
uh here you can see just how how crazy
the position is you can capture uh with
rook capture sun h1 you can play knight
capture sanjit you can play knight
captures on d1 win some material here so
there is so much that you can play here
but uh the absolute best move for
mamiyarov is a very very hidden one so
uh feel free to pause the video here and
try to find this hidden treasure while i
give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting a way out
out of this complete madness and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it's actually pawn to b3 yes
sometimes we have to you know
zoom out and uh look at the entire board
in order to
find the
the way out uh because now uh what
you've done is you control the c2 square
now queen to c2 could be a big problem
for white and we stop this by playing
knight to c5 okay now the queen does not
have access to c2 and after let's say
bishop captures pawn captures and queen
captures we play rook hdf1 uh this is i
mean of course impossible to spot now
queen to c2 here doesn't really do all
that much we're just going to move the
king and
there there's not a good continuation so
the absolute best for mamadara would be
rook 8 to f8 and now bishop captures on
d5 where you are asking yourself i i
don't even understand what is happening
anymore here but the point is if you
capture e captures on e5 then rook to g1
and the black just falls apart here uh
or maybe he can defend but it's going to
be very very tricky so what you should
play here is queen b4 just trade queens
and after let's say captures captures
we're going to play bishop characters
and e6 b captures an a2 with checking
captures and now we're going to pick up
this rook rook captures on f1 and you
get this position where prague would be
up upon but he would be down the
exchange however he still has the bishop
pair and the white should always be a
little bit better here uh
hard to say if it would be enough for a
win but
uh that's the way to defend with black
so if you've spotted b3 here then uh you
should seriously look into you know
playing playing professional chess
however madera played knight captures on
g2 and this will simply not do now
prague will play the rook h to g1 and
there's really no good way to defend
this it's very easy for white to just
pile up on the knights on the g file
monitor of christ defending with rook h2
but not just bishop f4 uh attacks the
the rook and the queen here knight
captures on f4 now comes rook captures
on g4 with check now we're gonna pick up
this knight as well uh or if the knight
goes back as it did in the game knight
to g6 now knight e5 now again we pile up
on this knight and if you play something
like rook to h6 which seems like it
defends the position there's the
incredible queen the e8 and now you
really don't have a way of uh
of playing this uh i mean just the the
the simple f8 check and then the queen
knight and rook are all going after that
g6 square uh this would be over very
quickly so mamadara played b3 now uh
it's a great move only a few moves too
late uh queen and now of course the
queen to c2 again is possible so queen
captures on b3 and rook to b8 trying to
give up a little material to make his
attack happen a little bit sooner uh but
now prague will just place rook captain
g6 king h7 and now the incredible rook
g2 uh andy was in this position yes on
the position from the thumbnail uh it
was in this position that shahir madara
resigned to the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
uh so really really a spectacular uh
game ahmedarov had the upper hand but
the prague was able to trick him
and of course if the queen is captured
then it's actually a forced check made
in eight but mahmoud saw this and of
course he did not want to play it out
the idea is rook captures on h2 with
check now it doesn't matter where the
king goes rook to g1 king to f6 and now
rook f2 check and now you don't have any
more squares you have to play rook f3
and rook captures on f3 will be
checkmate uh and that's all there is and
another thing after rook to g2 if you
don't capture the queen well what do you
play it's uh i mean there's really no no
good move if you play rook captures here
then queen h3 check and then you i mean
it's pretty much the same position only
white has a queen on the board so uh
that's not really going to work king g7
queen captures on g2 with check and i
mean that's that's just it and maybe uh
instead of this you could also go back
with something like rook to h6 but then
rook d to g1 and again you give up the
queen
i mean it's just uh it is just hard even
looking at this so real captures we're
going to play rogue g7 checking it
king h7 and the rook one to g7 will be
checkmate so uh beautiful position after
rook to g2 momidaro resigns and another
spectacular victory for prague who is uh
just destroying everyone in this
tournament we'll see if he can continue
playing with this strength uh he faces
geary next and magnus after that
but uh so far uh he he defeated jordan
twice with the black pieces and the the
one game with the white pieces he gotta
draw and here against mamadar he started
with a win with white then a draw with
black and then another win in game three
which pretty much repeated this line
only the queens got traded off the board
but uh prague was still out outplayed
mamadarov so a spectacular stuff uh uh
can't wait to see more but as usual you
guys are welcome to suggest some other
games that i will definitely look into
uh so yeah that's the game i hope you
guys enjoyed it and that you've spotted
that brilliant uh defending uh idea for
mahmoud that want to be three incredible
stuff uh so hope you enjoyed that as
well now i would like to thank usfdfri
nicholas padal andrew dabrovsky kirsten
lemmons uh and guy le fl scores for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of this
wonderful event uh until it finishes uh
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day